la rentrée parlementaire avait bien
commencé ce féliciter l'équipe de
François Legault toute la semaine il
s'était posé en défenseur du Québec face
à la nomination controversée de la
Représentante spéciale de la lutte
contre l'islamophobie à Ottawa je pense
que ce Trudeau
il faut fermer le chemin Roxane ça prend
une date butoir
quand le Parti québécois a réitéré ce
matin sa demande de fermer le chemin
Roxane les violons du gouvernement ne
semblaient pas tout à fait accorder si
les fermer il va simplement s'en recréer
un autre quelques kilomètres plus loin
donc ça ne règle absolument rien que de
proposer de fermer le chemin Roxane donc
ça rend la traversée plus périlleuse
pour des demandeurs d'asile potentiels
voici pourtant la position en mai
dernier on demande clairement au
gouvernement fédéral aujourd'hui Justin
Trudeau de fermer le chemin Roxane
et encore aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
de s'assurer de bloquer chemin Roxane ça
c'est la responsabilité du gouvernement
fédéral sa ministre ne
le compte-t-il mais Christine Frechette
a quand même senti le besoin de recadrer
son message je vais mettre quelque chose
au clair c'est que Roxane il faut que ça
ferme la fermeture ne signifie pas
d'installer une clôture si le Parti
québécois suggère d'envoyer la Sûreté du
Québec la ministre rappelle que c'est
plutôt au gouvernement fédéral de
refouler les gens la frontière et ça
passera par une renégociation entre les
États-Unis et le Canada moi j'ai dit ce
que j'avais à dire qui était en parfaite
concordance avec ce que le premier
ministre avance et puis je voulais juste
clarifier
un fouillis aussi pour ses collègues par
exemple une centaine de classes
d'accueil ont dû être créés depuis un an
à Montréal ses enfants on doit les
scolariser on doit pas les laisser
tomber sans parler des délais pour
obtenir un permis de travail
en veille à ce qu'il soit bien reçu on
veille à ce que les organismes et toutes
les ressources nécessaires Québec
continue d'exiger kotawa paye tous les
frais engendrés par l'arrivée massive de
demandeurs d'asile en attendant la
solution
ultime la fermeture du chemin Roxane
mais dans combien de temps personne ne
connaît la réponse ici Véronique prince
Radio-Canada Québec